one of the obvious goals to improve the
offensive line especially after they cut
their starting tackles eric fisher and
mitchell schwartz here is patrick
mahomes when he was asked about
the state of the offensive line and the
obvious efforts to make it better for
2021
yeah i mean i think we have a lot of
great guys in that offensive line room
guys that are ready to compete guys uh
that played last year and guys that have
a lot of experience coming in
and that that breeds competition and you
love that that's in every single room in
this in this locker room is competition
you're gonna go out there compete and
try to earn your way to earning a spot
and uh to find a way to be the best
player you can be to try to get us to
the super bowl based on the story last
year of andy and brad reaching out to
you during the first round of the draft
do you feel like you'll have a bit of a
say uh come this year with regards to
how to you know keep fortifying that
offensive line
yeah i mean i try i try to give my input
on on everything i can in this building
of trying to help out the team in the
best way possible
but at the end of the day i trust in and
veech and i trust in coach reed to make
the right decision for the the
betterment of the team um and so if they
ask me i'll give my input and do all
that do that different type of stuff but
they have a pretty good track
track record of getting great players in
this building
yes they do yeah yes they do oh
absolutely they do but you got to have
more than one yeah you got to have more
than patrick with homes they had great
players there already when they got
mahomes and they need to keep great
players around him and then you have
great players on the offensive line and
i like how he threaded the needle with
that question because one of the big
topics now in the nfl how much influence
will a quarterback have should a
quarterback have any acquisition of
talent whether it's tom brady aaron
rodgers russell wilson you throw patrick
mahomes in there as well he'll give his
input when he's asked but he's not going
to be showing up knocking on someone's
door with a list of players he wants to
see the team at yeah that's right i mean
i think you know
that's usually about as far as the
respect level goes between organization
and big time franchise quarterback you
know they might ask his opinion here and
there hey what do you think about this
guy what do you think about that player
all of that not that they're going to
just go oh patrick said this now let's
go upstairs and make that happen but
they're definitely going to listen to it
hey they know the guy studies football
then they know the guy's been around
athletes his whole life and can
recognize you know the good ones from
the bad ones and i think that's what the
smart teams do do is hey belichick
mcdaniels
listen to tom brady you know he's not in
the meeting saying but they might talk
about a player and they were gonna
they're gonna listen to tom and his
opinion they know he's been around the
block a few times and all that but he
wasn't gonna they weren't gonna like go
back into a personnel meeting and be
like we gotta cut that guy tom said he's
had enough of them no it's not quite to
that extent but i think that's the right
approach with the conversation there
between you know veach
andy reed and mahomes and i think it's a
healthy one
here's a reason why it raises the stakes
though yeah chiefs to get it right
moving forward when you convince patrick
mahomes to sign that
basically lifetime contract
more than a decade where the money is
awesome
but it's not market value he's already
been surpassed by dak prescott in less
than a year he will be surpassed by
others moving forward he's deliberately
left money behind so that they can put a
great team around him so
if they don't
he's got a beef a legitimate beef and
even if he's not
standing over anyone's shoulders saying
i want this i want that give me this
give me that
he can sit back and say
i expect greatness around you yes right
because i didn't do what i could have
done i didn't push this as far as i
could have i mean if he really wanted
to push the chiefs you're right he could
have said
i'm not doing a long-term deal
i'll take the franchise tag i'll take
another franchise tag and then
you'll give me
the biggest contract that's ever been
given to any player in the history of
sport
to get me to stay around that's what
will happen yeah that's what he could
have done yeah that's right he didn't
right he didn't because he wants to have
a great team around him yeah so if they
give him a great team fine if they don't
then you got a problem you're right
you're right mike i mean he really he
kind of in his own you know reverse
psychology way puts the pressure back on
them to go like all right i delivered
it's time for you to deliver kansas city
for the most part has delivered the last
you know five six really the whole andy
reid there handy andy reed brett veach
era there in kansas city they had they
are aggressive every year they make big
moves and free agency to try to get
things done you know so they've done a
great job even this year you know they
were active in recruiting trent williams
we know they got joe tooney from the
from the patriots hey jaron reed came
available they got him you know so
they're they're not afraid to go out
there and be aggressive and spend money
and do those type of things um they got
some work in the draft they probably got
to get another they got to get another
tackle to help help out patrick mahomes
um but you're right it's a it's a valid
point and i think kansas city and beech
and andy reid probably realize that and
know what the deal is
one last point for the benefit of those
who watched the show yesterday and
didn't catch the pftpm program later in
the day when we were discussing how
quarterbacks find anything and
everything
to allow them to have a chip on their
shoulder we mentioned tom brady and
being
snubbed in the draft 21 years ago right
but patrick mahomes has a little bit of
that too i gotta mention that chris
remember
when he when he beat the bears
the guy who was taken ahead of him he
starts counting off
ten
on his fingers sure because he was the
tenth pick that year sure and then last
year
when they were beating the ravens on
monday night football shredding the
ravens he counted off one two three four
because under the nfl top 100 players of
the year lamar jackson was one and
mahomes was four so he's got some that
he knows how to do it in a way that
doesn't really upset anyone or come off
as petty it comes off as charming right
but he's got it too
no doubt no doubt and and again it's
it's kind of what we talked about a
little yesterday right you know i'm sure
yeah that it's naturally in them but
they got in the league you lose an afc
championship game you feel a few
disrespects here or there and you start
to pay attention a little bit there's no
doubt he's a competitor he does do it in
a way that is very charming because for
whatever reason he doesn't go and
talk about it i guess a little bit it's
just it's on the field hey he knows
about it but he doesn't sit there and
lecture us or we don't have to hear nine
stories about how he's the greatest
competitor ever and he's never going to
forget about that so he does he's got a
very good way about you know kind of
delivering the message
and of course if trevor lawrence tries
to pull that move all he can do is one
that's again until i know
there's nothing you can use you got no
tools in the bag
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports